pour marquer ces deux jours de fête à
internet beaucoup d'expositions et de
conférences à travers tout le pays
à la cité des sciences de la villette à
paris on vous apprend à pianoter si vous
ne savez pas encore le faire et on vous
explique tout sur les e-mails le web et
autres maux de la génération
informatique romuald bonnant frédéric de
la rue si je vous dis web pour vous ça
veut dire quoi when i web c'est une
porte ouverte vers le monde
le web un inconnu pour les uns un espoir
pour les autres le web
en fait c'est une extraordinaire
bibliothèque électronique permettant
simultanément de recueillir des
informations d' écouter des sons de
visionner des images vidéos ou
virtuelles des données regroupées sur
des millions de sites informatiques à
travers la planète un monde sur
ordinateur accessible grâce à l'internet
mais c'est aussi un univers où il est
facile de se perdre eux sont venus à la
cité des sciences
justement pour s'y retrouver on est un
peu mais on a du mal à s'y retrouver
à l'aide de ces conférences on y voit un
peu plus clair
vous avez des choses mais je suis en
train d'apprendre souvient j'ai parlé
l'ascenseur conférences ateliers
d'initiation sur ordinateur balades
virtuelles
ici tout est prévu pour comprendre
comment ça marche mais aussi pour
démystifier la technique est guidé les
premiers pas sur l'internet c'est un
apprentissage qui suis très très vite
parce que les logiciels sont très
conviviaux l'heure actuelle donc c'est
quoi ces cinq dix minutes et puis très
vite les personnes sont complètement
autonome des apprentis internautes vite
séduit prêt à surfer sur le net surtout
au travail pour le moment
c'est peut-être un petit joujou mais je
pense que ça peut déboucher sur quelque
chose de plus intéressant sur le plan
professionnel je vois savoir comment on
peut monter un
gîtes de france en pleine montagne
j'ai essayé de 2 millions de français
utilisent l'internet c'est trois fois
moins qu'en allemagne en angleterre le
retard ne va pas durer car le mauvais
élève français et plein de bonne volonté